let's give ourselves some intuition and
then some practice adding negative
numbers so let's start with negative 11
plus negative 3.
so first we can visualize what negative
11 looks like on a number line like this
I intentionally have not marked off any
of the numbers we can just build an
intuition for what what's going to
happen here so if we're talking about
negative 11 you could think about that
as 11 to the left of 0 or if you start
at 0 right over here we are going to go
11 to the left which I'm just estimating
I have nothing marked here but let's
just say that gets us right about there
now to that I am going to add negative
3. so if I start at negative 11 and I
add negative 3 I'm going to go 3 more to
the left I'm going to go three more even
or even more in the negative Direction
so it's going to go something like that
and I'm going to end up even more
negative even further from zero further
further to the left from zero than I was
at negative 11. you might already be
guessing what that is but we'll we'll
think about that more in a little bit
let's do another example let's say
negative 11 plus 3 what would that look
like well we have the same negative 11
going on right over here which we
already Drew but now let me do plus 3 in
a different color and let me do it in
green so we don't get confused so
negative 11 plus 3. so if we start at
negative 11 right over here but now
we're adding 3. so now I'm going to go
into go to the right
so notice here I'm still ending up left
of zero on the number line so I still
going to end up in a negative place but
it is less negative it's left it's less
to the left that negative 11 was but
that's interesting I'm still going to
get a negative value now let's imagine
if I were to have positive 11 plus
negative 3. think about what would
happen there
so positive 11 let me do this in this
red color it might look something like
this positive 11 would look something
like that I'm starting at zero and I go
11 to the right and now I'm going to add
negative 3 to that
I'm going to add negative 3. so where I
left off here I'm now going to go 3 am I
going to go to the right or to the left
what's a negative 3 I'm going to go to
the left over here so it might get us
someplace right around there
so I went 11 to the right and then I go
3 to the left so I'm still going to end
up to the right I'm still going to have
a positive value but it's going to be
less positive than that 11 over there
now let's give one more scenario and
this is one that you're probably
familiar with for many years if I had
positive 11 plus 3
well I have that positive 11 in red
already over there and then if I were to
add 3 it would get me even more positive
and I think you know what that probably
is if you go even more positive so
there's a couple of interesting patterns
if we are adding numbers of the same
sign so for adding two negatives we
still end up with a negative if we add
two positives we still end up with a
positive
but when we're adding numbers of
different signs you actually end up
taking on the sign of whichever one is
further from zero so for example when I
took negative 11 plus 3 negative 11 plus
3. I still end up in I still end up with
an answer that is to the left of zero
something that is negative because 11 is
further to the left of 0 then 3 is
moving in the right direction
and then when we did 11 plus negative 3
it was the other way around
hopefully we've built up some intuition
and now I'm going to do is tackle these
exact same problems but we're going to
do it with an act with a number line
that actually has the numbers marked off
and we can actually compute what these
are going to be so let me delete all of
this and then let my me give ourselves
let's mark these things off and then
let's do the same ones over again
so if I were to say negative 11 plus
negative three what would that get us
and I'll try to remember the colors I
just used negative 11 I can start at 0
here and I'm going to go to the left 11.
and I get to whoops I'm a little bit too
far I'm gonna go all the way negative
five negative 10 right over here
negative 11 gets me right over there and
then to that I am going to add negative
three
So to that I'm going to do a different
color let me do this carefully to that I
am going to add negative 3. so I start
there and I'm going to go three more to
the left so one two three so I am going
to end up right over there and where do
I end up that is at negative 14. so this
is equal to
negative I'm just in a neutral color is
equal to negative
14.
now let's actually let's do this in
different orders just to to see what's
going on here let's let's do the
essentially something very similar but
let's go to the right of the number line
let's do 11 plus 3. so 11 plus 3 we
could start with positive 11. so let me
do that in Red so positive 11 would look
like that that's that right over there
and then I am going to add three so I'm
going to add 1 2 3 and I get to positive
14.
so notice here I ended up 14 to the
right of 0 here I ended up 14 to the
left of 0. but now let's look at the
scenarios where we had mixed signs so
let's say we have negative 11
plus 3. what do we think that is going
to be equal to
so we already have drawn negative 11.
that is negative 11 right over there and
now we want to think about plus three so
we're going to start right over here and
I'll do it a little bit higher so we can
see ourselves and then plus 3 we're
going to go 3 to the right from that
point so one two three where do we end
up well this right over here is negative
eight so we are now at negative
eight now let's do it let's do the other
way around if we had positive 11 plus
negative 3 what is that going to be
equal to well we've already drawn
positive 11 here
but now we're adding negative three
negative 3 is in this like salmon color
looking thing they're very close but
different so now we're going to add
negative 3 to positive 11. so we start
here but we're going to go 3 to the left
because it's negative so one two three
and where do we end up we end up at
positive 8.